our next speaker is and she is professor
of law at st. Mary's University and in
San Antonio Texas and a research fellow
at the Center for blockchain
technologies at University College in
London and she's going to present about
blockchain intermediaries hi everybody
thank you so much for having me it's
really exciting to get to meet people
who I have been you know following their
research for a number of years now so
thank you for having me thank you to
Peter particularly for having me cuz
we've had a lot of debates and it's I'm
excited to get to engage in some more of
those hopefully today so my presentation
is called intermediaries who must not be
named a legal and policy research agenda
for crypto miners so I have been
thinking generally about the parties
within blockchain systems for a long
time and how power is distributed among
them and what the implications are for
that power and that power distribution
for conclusions that we might draw from
a legal perspective a policy perspective
and a regulatory perspective okay so I'm
going to put a few quotes up that
demonstrate just how pervasive our
characterization of these systems is
that we describe them as having no
intermediaries as lacking intermediaries
okay so okay Locke chain creates the
opportunity for frictionless immutable
transfers of information or value
without an intermediary this is from the
chamber of digital commerce legislators
toolkit for blockchain technology that
this organization is a lobbying
organization for blockchain the
blockchain industry generally I had a
lot of quotes from Peter here so not
trying to pick on you but this
demonstrates his characters
okay a system without intermediaries is
a system without intermediary risk and
thus no need for regulation aimed at
safeguarding against the types of risk
presented by intermediaries right the
characterized these systems is lacking
intermediaries we immediately begin to
draw risk and policy and legal
conclusions based on that okay so this
was just in a blog that Peter wrote
talking about Bitcoin and Libra
differences okay here's a quote from
Alice Marcos who is a founder of chain
code labs one of the companies that
sponsors Bitcoin developers yes miners
should act as if they don't have agency
and our automatons we people who make up
the community should use social means to
encourage that I draw your attention to
they should act as if
okay here's some more from Peter new and
emerging company architectures can help
forge trustworthy relationships directly
between users without intermediaries the
most visible of these new systems thus
far is Bitcoin so this is Peter
testified went up against Nouriel
Roubini last year in Congress and this
was part of his testimony okay and then
this is a lot but this is an excerpt
from a letter to the Securities and
Exchange Commission sent by the one of
the lawyers for block staff this was a
company that did that did an s-1 I
believe eight or they they registered
with the SEC they were the first company
to actually do a registration statement
with the SEC for their tokens rather
than going kind of this but the Reg A+
that's what it was thank you so in in
communications with the SEC this is how
their lawyer characterized miners the
miners do not act as intermediaries in
making payments or deliveries by the
time they're involved in confirming and
recording transactions the transactions
have already occurred
other than being recorded without any
involvement by the miners the miners are
doing no more than implementing
mechanical paths that are used to
confirm those transactions occurred okay
nor they stand between any transaction
participants they generally don't know
who the parties are what assets are
involved where participants are anything
else that would let them play an
intermediary role okay so all of these
characterize these systems is lacking
intermediaries and talk about how miners
are not intermediaries in these
transactions okay I think this is not a
great characterization of these systems
and I think it actually has really
important consequences so today I'm
going to argue that viewing systems
blockchain systems as ones without
intermediaries is actually quite
misleading and very consequential
for for a variety of reasons okay so
I'll talk about how I actually see
miners as intermediaries within these
systems and I'll tell you why and how
I'm characterizing intermediary
in that way I'll give you examples of
ways that I have seen just you know
watching the crypto space of miners
acting as intermediaries and highlights
some computer science research that
emphasizes this
if I have time I'm going to tease out
some of the sumption 'z that people are
making when we describe blockchain
systems as lacking intermediaries I I
have a feeling that for my conversations
with people it seems like people are
comfortable describing blockchain
systems as having no intermediaries
because of certain analyses that they're
kind of doing silently where they're
comfortable saying well we should treat
them as if they are not they have no
intermediaries because of these
conclusions that I have not articulated
okay and then finally I think there's
actually a lot more research that is
needed in this area and it's research
about the mechanics of blockchain
systems that is probably going to come
from computer scientists and economists
but all of this research very much
implicates legal conclusions and policy
conclusions so I think it all has to
work together so I'm going to lay out
some open research questions that I'm
that I think are essential for us to
better understand this okay so first of
all what am I talking about when I'm
using the term intermediary this is a
very inflammatory word I have learned in
discussing this in various contexts and
all I am using this word to mean is the
most basic lay definition okay an
intermediary is a middleman right it's
someone who is between me and you that I
have to go through if I want to get to
to you okay so it's a party you have to
go through to accomplish something I'm
not using an intermediary in a way that
is a legal term here I'm not using it in
the sense of financial intermediaries to
describe kind of what banks do right and
they transform obligation they transform
obligations in a way through their magic
I'm not talking about that I'm simply
talking about someone is in the middle
okay I'm also not talking about the
intermediary
who are outside of the blockchain
systems right we're comfortable talking
about exchanges and wallet providers as
intermediaries I'm not talking about
them also in this conversation I'm not
talking about non mining nodes I'm
specifically focusing on on miners
although I think that we should be you
know asking similar questions about
nodes but I haven't gotten there yet
okay so my definition of intermediary a
very basic lay definition middleman sure
yes within these systems
I am the this is this this paper is
really about miners here so nodes may I
have not thought through it yet nodes
may also end up falling into this
category for me but I haven't done the
deep thinking about that yet so this
paper is me thinking about miners as
intermediaries okay why do I think about
miners as intermediaries great yeah
that's going to be another important
definitional issue absolutely I have I'm
focusing in this paper primarily on on
Bitcoin and using I'm using the term
miners because that's all over the
literature it's very tricky I agree with
you I think that parties that we're
referring to as validators or record
keepers Baker's potentially right I'm
really interested in the people that are
actually writing to the blockchain the
people who have the ability to create
the record I'm my discussion will
primarily be focused on Bitcoin but I
think a lot of these points that I'll
make extrapolate to other systems to the
record keepers in them how do you make
the distinction between for example
pools and workers in the
yep right I'm thinking you're probably
the pool manager I think the pool
managers are are the the most obvious
ones here this is going to have to be
taken apart but and I know there is a
lot of experimentation and there are
proposals to help to take back some of
the power from pool operators
particularly in Bitcoin
so that absolutely will play into the
analysis okay why am I thinking about
miners as intermediaries well these
these public blockchains occur on
peer-to-peer networks right there is no
central server and I think that that's
the main reason people are comfortable
describing them as lacking
intermediaries and I think that that may
have been it may have been pretty fair
to characterize these systems as lacking
intermediaries maybe at the very
beginning okay when you didn't have
these big mining mining pools
discrepancies in power a really stark
divide between mining nodes and purely
just validating nodes non mining nodes
so there's an important distinction here
between different players on the
blockchain right it's a peer-to-peer
network but only some of those parties
actually get to write okay not all the
peers get to write to the blockchain and
you don't get to put your transaction on
the blockchain on the ledger unless a
miner puts it there okay so I see them
as this middle party right that each
peer has to go through in order to
actually get their transaction on the
ledger okay if a miner can affect things
about your transaction maybe the time
it's actually processed or the order in
which your transaction gets processed
then they can affect you right they
stand in the middle between you getting
your transaction on the ledger and they
may be able to do things about it we'll
talk about some of the things that they
can do in a moment does this put them in
the middle and if they're in the middle
they may pose a middleman
of risk and I think that this is really
important because if we just kind of
habitually characterize the systems as
lacking intermediaries and don't
appreciate the middleman risk posed by
minors within them then our risk
analyses are flawed the conclusions that
we draw our flawed the policy decisions
that we make based on those analyses are
flawed legal conclusions are flawed etc
so I think a lot more research is
necessary here okay so what can miners
do as intermediaries that we might worry
about that we might think well if they
could do this maybe they do post some
kind of risk to me as I am trying to get
my transaction to another party alright
we've seen that right they can rewind
transactions if they if they get a
certain amount of hashing power on the
network right
we saw transactions rewound following
the Dow you had to have a certain amount
of miners involved with this we saw two
you know great discussion in the Bitcoin
ecosystem after the big finance hack
happened right on Twitter a software
developer proposed well why don't you
just bribe the miners they suggested to
the head of the exchange that he should
just bribe the miners to undo the heck
right and this was viewed as kind of he
said the unsayable thing right you can't
that's not true right Bitcoin is
immutable so you can't even admit that
someone could choose to rollback the
transaction but it would be miners
making the decisions there about whether
that happened like you said something
silly not unsalable I think
people who I look to in the community is
reasonable felt that what what was being
proposed was absurd not that it was
unsayable but that it was never going to
work and indeed it it didn't right they
didn't they didn't attempt it right but
I don't know yeah it's absolutely
important to note that there is a chain
one of those transactions were not
rewound absolutely and it was merely the
choice of users to use one chain or the
other that was influential because if
aetherium has forked without the dow
transactions was simply not interesting
to users it would have traded lower than
aetherium classic and in fact the
reverse was true to me it was the users
by preferring to trade ether rather than
ether classic in the long run as we look
at the difference actually made the
choice yeah I think that there is a
really important larger conversation
that needs to happen here about this
power of users it's user activated soft
fork and this ties into the larger
conversation about our users protected
purely through having the right to you
know like fork off right exit versus
voice in did the miners reverse the
transaction or the users metaphysically
I don't think you can actually say
either is entirely true okay yes yes you
must trust made a choice for you okay
yeah that's something that I want to
talk about here is how much control does
the intermediary have to have in order
for us to consider them relevant and
posing a risk right does does it have to
be absolute control or does it have to
be a some control in the matter right so
yep that's kind of on my list
I think Primavera had her hand up
[Music]
[Music]
well okay so this actually also goes
into the conversation about
okay that may be a fair point I'm not
sure I want to give on it but I'll take
your planet can we discuss it further in
a moment
okay one more the way I see we
definitely still have these
intermediaries we just put them in this
competitive market setting and what
Peter's basically saying is you know
they're driven by market forces you know
they can choose to ignore them but at at
their own loss right they'll suffer a
loss for that I can see kind of the both
sides of the earth yep of course they
still pose a systemic risk as they band
together and and somehow perfectly do
this but but usually they are affected
by market forces and with the tide you
know either with your own classic or
overnight
the theory is that the game theory keeps
them in check in their economic
incentives do as well that was that what
you're saying yep
yeah that's one of the items on my
research agenda absolutely like how far
can we trust the game theory right does
game theory do everything for us that we
would expect legal and regulatory
actions otherwise to do I'm not sure
that we have enough certainty in the
game theory yet to to make that to say
that that's that's great
that's a that's a conclusion that we
draw now and of course this always comes
with the caveat of in what way are you
seeing these systems used right are you
seeing them used in a systemically
important way for you know socially
important practices are you just seeing
them used in a kind of walled garden
people opt into them on their own how
many links are there to the existing you
know financial system and the other
other parts of the the non crypto world
okay ordering transactions to their
benefit so right miners then in here
it's my understanding it's the mining
pool operators right choose what order
they want to put transactions in to the
to the blocks and as we see in you know
the financial markets more generally
deciding what order things happen and
the timing of certain financial events
can have huge consequences right the
system can be gained by manipulating
ordering and Phil Diane and others at
Cornell wrote an important paper flash
boys 2.0 which you have probably all
seen that talked about how the the
layering of other systems on top of the
the base layer can change the incentives
of the minors within the base layer and
enable them to manipulate the system in
certain ways okay
maybe they can censor transactions so
there was an example of this potentially
happening in Z cash a number of months
ago when it was discovered that one of
the main minors
didn't have nearly as many of the
shielded transactions that it was mining
as it should have given you know its
participation level in the blockchain so
there was some speculation that oh maybe
they're deliberately choosing not not to
process shielded transactions which if
every miner made that decision well that
kind of means that no shielded
transactions are getting are getting
processed and that kind of undermines
the the confidentiality privacy goals of
the system so it's from you know Twitter
again some conversations on Twitter the
the mining pool operator said oh it was
an intentional that I was doing this I
just hadn't taken the trouble to
implement implement that the software
the proper way to process those so it
was just me being lazy and not me being
deliberate of course this highlights the
fact that there's absolutely choice
involved here and if you know lots of
miners did that then how would the
confidential attraction transactions end
up on the blockchain it's also important
the censoring point kind of in our
discussion that we're having about you
know control versus maybe like influence
here
that do they have to be able to censor
something indefinitely before we
actually care or is it only censoring it
you know a little bit even if it's not
indefinite I think it actually actually
matters a lot because the idea with
these blockchain systems is that you
don't have anyone in the middle you can
get your financial transactions
processed without having to have someone
make a decision in the middle okay
and this kind of refers to the the
research that's happening generally
about how adding layers above these Corp
protocols alters the incentives as I
said at the protocol level and may give
the miners additional opportunities to
exploit their their intermediary role
and I didn't list all the research here
I was kind of rushing on the slides but
there is there are quite a number of
papers that have come out recently on
this and I can get the list for anyone
who is interested how does this matter
hey well I think our conclusions that we
draw from a legal and a regulatory and a
policy perspective flow from our
understandings about the facts within
these blockchain systems if we view
these systems is lacking intermediaries
and there's actually some really
important people in them acting as
middlemen and shaping what ends up on
the blockchain exploiting different
opportunities that they have to based on
their role as writers to the blockchain
then we need to consider them in our
legal relative regulatory and policy
decisions and right now I think a lot of
the decisions that are being made in
this area view these systems as lacking
intermediaries okay so go ahead question
we want to view if with your the system
completely running code no because
people are making choices to run code to
craft code and yeah go ahead
I knew it exists but they didn't know
that it's so clear I see that okay we
can have a blockchain what will be the
mining group and with with a block there
will be a certificate by running this
code that we agreed on so essentially no
human intervention aside from the
decision to want the code or not to run
the code so we can in some way
completely automate the system from my
perspective what I watch is these
systems are not completely automated
right yeah and I I would be skeptical of
course I'm not a computer science
scientists but I would be skeptical that
you can get to that point where it is a
completely automated system I think that
humans tend to find the spots where
things
give them an opportunity to manipulate
and I see these systems as attempting to
shut down as many of those opportunities
as possible but they still exist and I
think humans find those so I would be
skeptical that we'd actually get there
what could we build the system you know
here is a block I did mining that I
didn't get proving that you did not do
something is very hard nearly impossible
what are you just gonna take the miners
word for it that I didn't get a bribe
off chain to process things a particular
way I'm not sure that you can reach
those kind of actions in how you mind
they're not provable by code okay choose
to delay messages which is ascent the
essence of selfish mining these delaying
messages and not sending them out this
is something you couldn't prove that
Qingdao nor did we do because it's
outside of your computer right it's you
could you do all right
you could to do to connect to and who
not to connect to and so I would even
look at relay networks as intermediaries
that are possibly far more centralized
than then the miners themselves right
you could choose a lot of things right
the the algorithm also you could say you
know I didn't see that last block and so
I I did act according to code so you can
always restrict information pretend as
if you didn't receive messages right so
there's no way to prove the correctness
of your behavior if the input is
manipulated by by the miner externally
okay so I think we're in many ways
making decisions based on the view that
minors do not act as intermediary isn't
just a few examples of this right minors
are not treated as money transmitters by
FinCEN which is the the part of the
Treasury Department that deals with
money laundering around the world and
has rules for how banks have to police
money laundering so they're not treated
as many transmitters they're the New
York bitlicense
affirmative ly doesn't cover minors it's
it's a pretty it's it's viewed as I
would say pretty controversial when
people suggest that minors are
functioning in ways that are very
similar or analogous to parties in the
financial system like brokers or people
involved in into clearing of
transactions etc it's it's very
controversial still to to suggest those
things there are signs that the tide may
be shifting I believe it was last fall
oh fak who maintains a list of you know
parties you can't do business with
because they're suspicious right you
can't send money to these people they
put some Bitcoin addresses on that list
and I I would think that the only way
that could be enforced is if minors are
not supposed to be sending transactions
from or to those addresses
okay
so I'm just going to put up a whole
bunch of questions up here Jason well
this paper is not taking a stance on it
but I think that if we view if we take a
deeper look at what miners are doing
then we need to be willing be willing to
go where that leads us and potentially
rethink a lot of regulatory and legal
classifications that we've made based on
this belief I understand however I think
it was a self conscious decision by the
New York Department of Financial
Services to not regulate language now
you're suggesting that they made that
decision with bad information yes with
respect to Vinson it's a we haven't had
new law here since Bitcoin they hire
much older and FinCEN offered guidance
in 2013 and again in 2019 explaining how
they see those old laws the way they
were written back before Bitcoin not
fitting into cryptocurrencies Vinson was
bound because they can't create new law
they can make new regulation yes yep
fully interpreting the letter of those
old rules Quinn Center and others
suggested look a plain reading of the
rules suggests that you're only a money
services business for purposes of Pinson
if you accept and transmit currency
substitutes from one person to another
one location to another a plain reading
of accept and transmits suggests at
least transitory custody over a
financial asset over a currency or a
substitute and I think we made in good
faith an argument that a minor though
they may be in the plain language an
intermediary they are not accepting and
transmitting from one
- another one location to another no I
agree that your argument was made in
good faith absolutely absolutely I think
it's it's fair to say that how we
describe these things as intermediaries
or not may color those those decisions
but I don't think in the case of Vinson
that was the case I think Vinson has a
lot of good information about this New
York Department of Financial Services I
won't I won't a hard one argue does or
does not
FinCEN had good information and made a
good call on the letter of the law and
they have the power the Secretary of
Treasury has the power to add a new
category of financial institution and
define it however they like potentially
defined minors as financial institutions
we would argue that that's the step too
far but right that's a that's a policy
choice by a previous understanding of it
right so in the in the in the different
reports from regulators that I that I
cite in the paper there are it's a
pervasive characterization of these
systems as minors are not in meters
there are no intermediaries within these
and transmit and I this is not the
argument that I'm really interested in
having today but sorry but I think that
you could write the the questions around
like what does it mean to hold this
asset right and to transmit the asset
you're right they may not be in perfect
alignment with our existing categories
but I think that underlying it they are
doing something that people can't
transmit their value right unless they
go through them so you could argue right
that they are doing the transmission of
value because it is their cementing the
transaction in the blockchain that
achieves the transmission right yeah
okay what we haven't heard from you so
in an earlier slide you said it's used
by intermediaries sort of a yes to
conventional financial intermediaries
yeah I think maybe and then in this
light you're sort of slipping in that
direction
yes yeah I think we can all agree that
in some sense miners or nodes in general
are intermediaries you have to go
through the should we think of them as
more like financial intermediaries or
should we think of them as more like
ISPs we're also for the same absolutely
absolutely yes they're there gates right
so we're in that spectrum do they lie
right absolutely I think that's part of
the research agenda and I can't remember
if I added it to my list of questions or
not but questions around like network
neutrality and and antitrust and
collusion issues those absolutely need
to be thought about in that in the
context of the actual facts about the
blockchain fact list is a list of
sanctions the Office of Foreign Assets
Control it's a division of Treasury that
enforces US sanctions it says if a bank
makes a transfer to person in Iran who's
on the sanctions list which if they're
in a rounded probably are the bank is
going to be responsible for it
and so both fact decided to add some
Bitcoin addresses to that list now they
say to make a transfer to this Bitcoin
address you're responsible both to both
individuals who initiate the transfer
potentially to minors I think absolutely
to miners in fact who put the the
transfer in the blockchain but it also
would apply to an isp a Bitcoin
transaction message is not encrypted the
of the same transaction message the
Bitcoin address is viewable to the ISP
if they do packets anything if they look
at I think actually this is very
interesting I haven't thought about this
an ISP probably they relay a Bitcoin
transaction
message with an address on it that is is
on the sanctions list yeah that that I
think there is something there with that
packet sniffing analogy and I'm kind of
jumping ahead here to the research
agenda but I think part of the empirical
research that I am proposing and I'm I
would guess that much of this is already
going on but I just haven't found it all
yet is that we need to be thinking
carefully about you know what can miners
tell about the identity of parties who
are transacting transacting on the
blockchain right the the messaging
around it is that you know this is all
automated so no one's going and checking
and stuff but if we have companies like
chain alysus and those who are doing
forensics and can identify with pretty
good certainty I don't know what the
thresholds are but have figured out how
to identify parties behind different
transactions in a number of situations
well why wouldn't we assume that miners
would use that same kind of technology
to identify who is behind what addresses
if it's beneficial to them if they're
taking bribes or whatever to order
transactions a particular way etc and if
you like the blockchain it's a
particular way so I think we need a lot
of empirical work on how miners operate
I think they have just not gotten the
scrutiny yet so I think we need to look
at this is the Warriors contracts of
mining pools what kind of how you know
what kind of power are these hashes
giving to the mining pool operator do
they get to choose everything are you
doing that research did I miss your
presentation or something
okay okay I assume that incredible that
in just enter a program on a software
and they start mining without any being
aware of what they are doing and I think
advanced to spy while you were talking
about miners and they're here which I
follow to convene them responsible but I
wonder for what because except for the
last clue that canes up that we can ever
least a big kind of dresses like a black
Lisa as it was for bank account I'm not
sure but this might be a logical black
if they can see the provenience of the
money if they're legal and whatever so
as long as we don't have any control
into the merit of the transaction would
it be irresponsible what for miners are
just like Keanu is a boolean computing
very vague with very deep skills in
computer so I that's why I think this
research is so incredibly important
right how easily can miners Pierce right
the the anonymity of parties transacting
on the blockchain I had a lot of
questions about them right so I just
mentioned the contracts of the mining
tools and what the power is that them
the pool operator has versus the
different hashers within the pool so
miners are important in the context of
like bug fixes and software upgrades
what kind of vetting are they doing of
the software when they before they
upgrade right so in the Bitcoin
inflation bug of the fall of 2018 right
we get the description
the bug report the the CVE whatever
number that you know the core developers
contacted slush pool and slush pool lake
within a number of minutes confirmed
that they had upgraded did they get this
right the conversation is such that
these systems are so incredibly
complicated that you have to have
unbelievable expertise and how they work
and history and all the interconnections
of the software before anyone can
actually be trusted to make changes to
the code but the miners are apparently
taking you know software the the cortes
word that just run this it doesn't
suggest to me that they've done any
bidding what are their cybersecurity
practices right who knows right I've
heard anecdotally from people that
they're not great right but it could
matter from from my perspective if you
know their cybersecurity practices are
exploited to knock significant amounts
of computing power off the system we
don't know what they're doing to protect
against that this off chain bribing
happen right there's been a lot of
theoretical different types of bribing
attacks proposed in the computer science
literature I don't know how you would
ever find this out but it would be great
if we could know if it's really
happening or not maybe someone needs to
go undercover as an ethnographer and go
and check I don't know if anyone has
ideas on that that'd be great so I it
bribing does yeah you're right have that
connotation yes yeah right and and I'm
picking up on the term that is used in
these computer science papers but you're
right should be characterized as bribing
or not are they are they're off chain no
you're right right are their payments
outside the system that are not
reflected on the blockchain that you
have accepted to process transactions
right because we know the ones that show
up on the ledger right the transaction
fees that are attached to the the
different proposed transactions but we
don't know about stuff that's not on the
ledger how yeah
[Music]
is that it's that narrow I'm sorry Oh
interesting
okay prioritization of transactions if
you prioritize someone's transaction
you're basically circumventing them the
market forces like you're not off you're
not you're not
market is not enclosed in that it's an
exclusive a contract with someone that
I'll clear all their transactions nobody
else gets to compete so I'm I'm somehow
making more money as a result
institutionally sort of common and
accepted way of doing things and then
parties engage inside payments and
there's some circumstances in which side
payments are extremely beneficial but
some circumstances in which they're
supposed to be an incentive structure
and the side payments are not to a
beneficial event Yeah right right
because right the all the incentive
structure baked into these block chains
and why we would be comfortable
potentially saying that we don't have to
worry about the legal and regulatory
stuff because people's behavior is
constrained by the incentives designed
and baked into the system well these
kind of things happen outside the system
that affects that entire analysis right
how are the different mining pools
connected in the real world I mean
there's speculation about there's one
guy behind X number of mining pools but
I would like to know that because I
think it's absolutely relevant in
figuring out people's ability to
actually manipulate the transactions on
the ledger over time this problem will
actually become better if I'm just
better just like less privately because
if right block is Bitcoin or other
occurrences more widely adopted and that
makes that those traditional legacy
having a human system the best use the
cost of doing assignments become larger
so the atomic incentives just pushing
through the court or people are not
doing inside payment or private it's so
constant to do it off change why is it
costly to do it off chain I don't so now
so many like millions of people are
using the payment network or like say
credit card payment networks but now
suppose that just like the blockchain
payment has become to a point that
everybody is adopting so so few people
are using those jaga's e-payments
anymore and companies are exiting the
market and it becomes just like say for
example to go to Sweden and people say
they're kind of can't cancel chat it's
really difficult for dumb people do you
can actually have to do it off the chain
you can pay site payment using Bitcoin
just won't show up on the record as tied
to those transactions it's probably then
better not to say off the chain side
payments it's better to say Yeah right
neither transaction fee nor block reward
yeah in the sense like a bribe you to
rollback by putting something yep
different really just from putting in
because there's no competition you're
not offering other miners a chance to
get that payments right please do yes I
think if we start to view miners like
you know it's part of this critical
infrastructure right if this was a bank
right the regulars would come and say
you know you need redundancy in
communication you've redone since data
and so on my fear is like that you know
miners are they're trying or pools maybe
are they're trying to save costs so
they're not building up necessarily all
the redundancy you want all right so
that's where the market is leading them
workers who come to the pools right
there's an information problem you you
don't know how much redundancy them your
pool has actually purchased you can see
how much you're paying any fees for
example what percentage you leaving them
but you have no idea how how about there
and usually you don't care and so if we
think of this as a systemic risk right
cyber security practices are a part of
this payment that that you know mining
pools have to keep expanding really what
you want to do is just regulate this as
if it was critical infrastructure or any
so rightly the powerbreathe and so on
stupid around the world it's right not
necessarily just to stop transactions
from going into places we don't like I'm
not sure that's the right way to to
regulate payments that that could be
done it exchanges right back right entry
into the conventional banking system and
yeah I think my different they're
different questions there's like the
cheating consumer protection cheating
question versus the systemic stability
question yeah now is not is not a
systemic consequence for them you know
for the world economy but but you know
we might get there and and then I think
some of these things would be working
right so so maybe that's a interesting
yep okay what else is on here
okay so I know research is beginning on
this but I think this is is absolutely
critical how do the upper layers the
interactions between the upper layers
and the base layer affects these minor
incentives and opportunities and this is
you know interesting because all of the
this defy structure is being built up
atop aetherium and I know that there are
efforts to do similar things in in
Bitcoin and right that's part of the
vision now is that there are these upper
layers there are also lots of financial
products that people are proposing that
are not like in the defy area but are in
the the more legacy financial system
area right we've got futures products
there's that the CFTC the Commodity
Futures Trading Commission share
predicted recently that you would see
etherium futures and I think he said six
months or something like that so and
then there's also speculation about a
Bitcoin ETF be imminent
okay how do our understandings of these
systems change and the risks embedded in
them once all these upper layers are
built on okay so this is here's a few
questions that try to get at you know
why are we comfortable describing these
systems as lacking intermediaries okay
one of them one of the arguments that I
see people making to say you're crazy
when you characterize them as
intermediaries is because they are it's
not a single party who is always the
intermediary right
you don't necessarily you don't know who
the miner is going to be that is going
to process your transaction you can't
identify them in advance right it's the
idea that they win this lottery and even
if they have you know a certain huge
percentage of the hashing power right
they're not guaranteed 100% to be the
winner so do do we understand these
risks are they different kinds of risks
posed by intermittent eat of
intermediaries and apart to say they
like it
are those different risks than are more
standard intermediaries right I think
people have become comfortable saying
well they're not intermediaries because
they're intermittent I think we need to
press harder there okay have we actually
just broken up this intermediary this
one central intermediary into multiple
intermediaries and pieces do we need to
think about obligations that each minor
as a potential intermediary to come in
for a second and act as sinners an
intermediary we have to grapple with
that we haven't thought through that
question yet at least from the research
that I have done there's an intermediate
does an intermediary need control to be
considered that that seems to be an
underlying assumption and conclusion
that people are drawing right that if
they can't force people to upgrade their
software that they can't censor a
transaction forever right then it's not
fair to call them intermediaries they
don't look the same way
well they might just be a different kind
of intermediary and maybe intermediary
isn't even the right word here but I
feel like because of these vocabulary
issues were glossing over some of these
important questions and then this is the
question that you were just talking
about should minors be viewed as
critical infrastructure providers do do
they now view themselves this way from
you know anecdotal conversations that
I've had no they don't seem to but as
the systems grow do we need to treat
them in this way
here's more is the game theory embedded
in blockchains robust enough to replace
legal and regulatory structures right
this this question has already come up
in our conversation today right do we
trust that these economic incentives
that you know are being designed into
the systems but those really work well
enough to where we can say you don't
have to worry about governing these
people through legal or regulatory means
the economic incentives do everything
I'm very skeptical okay
I think you know this empirical research
and these other theoretical questions
that I have asked lead us to have to
potentially rethink existing legal
conclusions that we've drawn about these
systems right because I'm not sure that
we have understood them well enough to
or those conclusions that we drew in the
past right the systems have changed in
important ways over time they're
evolving so maybe these conclusions are
you know need to be rethought right
we've mentioned the money transmitters
are they transfer agents are they
brokers and I are they fiduciaries
potentially but I don't know can miners
engage in insider trading right is that
what they're doing if they take side
payments to prioritize a particular
transaction or if they get inside
knowledge like the the the first miner
slush pool who heard about the Bitcoin
bug right can they engage in insider
trading if they exploit that knowledge
in some way right that that knowledge
that they got before other miners or
before the regular nodes should miners
have to meet governance and risk
standards that we impose on other
financial market infrastructure this was
the question that was asked earlier as
as these systems become more important
miners be regulatory access points to do
things like anti money laundering
checks to help to stop deaths from
exchanges
right now we're as I've been in
conversation with people who are doing
these forensics and they they talk about
how they look at you know the flows of
the money after an exchange has a has a
theft and talking about well tell other
exchanges not to process transactions
that have come from there but could you
stop it at the minor level and say
miners you can't you can't send that
money that's been stolen on okay there
are more I didn't have time to put all
the principles for that should guide
this research but there are some
important ones that have been
highlighted by various people in the
audience already right there are
different roles performed by different
actors within these mining ecosystems
okay people who just contribute hashing
power are different than mining pool
operators and there are a whole bunch to
my understanding of different structures
of these mining pools and cloud mining
and so any analysis has to take that
into account each blockchain system is
unique okay we've been talking primarily
about Bitcoin that I think a similar
analysis would be very useful and
similar research would be incredibly
useful on all of these different
blockchain ecosystems the tech and the
practices are fast-moving and ever
evolving so stuff that you learn may not
be useful for that long and you'll have
to continue updating to follow the tech
and that's where I've gotten to I think
there are lots of interesting questions
here so thank you and happy to continue
to discuss maybe we have time for one
question and then we can take offline we
are running a little high
because we've been focused on Bitcoin
there's sort of a quite a lot of
centralization the miners you can think
of them as sort of these big farms with
a lot of money but you think of systems
maybe you know the current systems all
have the structure with the other very
similar technically with the newer
systems some of them you know might have
far more distributed suppose instead of
like this few pools of giant miners you
would have you know a hundred thousand
miners that are mostly I think that
certainly would change any legal and
policy conclusions that you draw from
the systems right I I think that the
important part is to see these people
and to think about what kind of risks do
they potentially pose can what actions
can they take so that question that I
talked about how have we just how do we
think about an intermediary that has
been just like fragmented right it's not
gone it's just broken into a million
pieces do we impose the same obligations
that the old one big intermediary had on
every one of those fragments do we
impose different obligations on them I
this is kind of like I don't have a
conclusion there for you I would think
they would have less fewer obligations
because they pose fewer risks right it's
it seems like it would be harder for
them to control the ordering you know
and like I think the risks are different
so the risks are different your legal
conclusions are different okay thank you
guys so much I learned a lot already
thank you